à villarceaux le fil de l'eau remonte le
cours du temps
depuis le moyen-âge l'homme en
maîtrisant l'élément liquide à modeler
ici ses paysages un jeu de cascades de
miroirs de biefs et des temps où les
jardins se côtoient en harmonie les
perspectives les couleurs et les formes
chaque époque a joué ici sur son
registre
la ressource et c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire parce que villarceaux
raconte la relation entre entre l'homme
et la nature raconte cette relation
pendant 700 ans
le site a été incroyablement préserver
tout ça s'est déroulé presque au compte
gouttes
c'est un peu le oui c'est une histoire
c'est toute une histoire d'eau
villarceaux ça a commencé par parler par
les viviers et puis doucement on a il ya
toute une stratégique qui a été mise en
place par les anciens le domaine géré
aujourd'hui par le conseil régional
depuis six ans les chantiers de
restauration se poursuivent un travail
d'archéologie et d'architecturé a permis
de restituer les paysages l'articulation
des jardins et de redonner vie aux deux
château du domaine site exceptionnel
villarceaux a même l'ambition de devenir
un centre international de l'art des
jardins un projet pour l'instant un
sommeil
pour ce qui concerne la création de
jardins nouveau plus exactement
l'évocation de desjardins du monde
le projet est actuellement différer les
temps sont durs financièrement et
compris pour la région par contre pour
ce qui concerne la restauration des
autres jardins jardin à la française à
l'italienne petit jardin de curé jardin
sur l'eau douce la continuer au rythme
des saisons et des progrès dans
l'agitation
l'an dernier quatre mille personnes ont
pu découvrir villarceaux pendant
quelques week end
cette année le domaine ouvre plus
largement ses portes tous les samedis et
dimanches après midi de la fin avril à
la fin octobre
l'occasion de retrouver ces jardins
oubliés du vexin